[Musique]
cueillie directement de l'arbre en
compote en tarte ou en jus la pomme est
populaire c'est le deuxième fruit le
plus consommé chine
mais elle fait partie de la célèbre
liste des dirty dozen une compilation
des douze fruits et légumes contenant
les plus fortes quantités de pesticides
selon mme aucun souci à consommer des
pommes locales
[Musique]
au verger sainte olle on compte plus de
50000 pommiers qui peuvent être aspergé
une quinzaine de fois avec différents
aguerris ces logiciels ils essaient
petit sid chaque année malgré cela le
propriétaire se veut rassurant je m'en
rappelle jamais de croquer dans une
pomme que je cueille dollar ben à
l'automne mois mais sans nécessairement
labourdins ce pourquoi sa figure parmi
la liste des dirty dozen parce que on
est une des cultures comme le plus de
tonnage à l'hectare d'application à
l'hectare par année on n'y va pas avec
parfois une autre et non il vaut
vraiment de façon raisonnée pour voir
les plus beaux fruits possible la pomme
c c'est vraiment une culture qui que
beaucoup d'ennemis robert laffont fait
appel aux services de l'agronome
sébastien beauchamp qu'il est dans la
culture de la pomme parfait dans ce
verger
cette technique se veut plus écologique
d'ailleurs 80% des pommes produites au
québec sont maintenant cultivés ici en
mode production fruitière intégrée
ici chacun cib ils sont les vingt sept
se font sous mac active savannah selon
leur gestion la santé doivent suivre les
doses qui sont recommandées dessous les
produits les prix des près du chemin qui
était relativement dispendieux
quand la personne croit m plus de
tonnage à l'hectare plus de quantité que
leurs camarades parce que ça lincou
directement économiques liées à la
rentabilité la culture de la pomme c'est
une importante industrie si près de 500
producteurs juste au québec et des
revenus de plus de 59 millions de
dollars
l'objectif premier des pomiculteurs
c'est d'avoir des pommes par fait part
ce sont elles sur les plus payantes
si on le traite po lille pourrait avoir
une grande majorité des freaks qui vont
défendre mais comme ça c'est une grosse
perte de revenus pour les producteurs
présentement la pomme qui a une petite
perforation une petite déformation
dépendant de la grosseur ou de la
tolérance qu'on offre des classe c est
que vous un fruit qui est pas parfait
c'est une perte
c'est une perte une pomme dans la jouer
à terre vaut environ 500 de la ligue 1
sauf mer plein de prendre une belle
pomme valoir une pièce la ligue
est-ce que nous serions prêts en tant
que consommateurs acheter des pantins
parfaite avec moins de pesticides
c'est sûr que les consommateurs
québécois h attend encore beaucoup avec
les yeux sur un petit peu plus
d'éducation pour allez économiser
facilement quelques traitements par
année des frais un petit peu moins
parfaits niveau avec tous ces épandages
que reste-t-il dans nos pommes
nous avons consulté des analyses faites
par l'agencé canadienne d'inspection des
aliments et malgré de nombreux résidus
de pesticides tout les 250 pomme analysé
en moyenne chaque année
respecter les normes même résultat au
québec
mais cette fois le mapaq analysé
seulement 41 mais c'est certainement pas
suffisant pour avoir un vrai portrait
mais ça donne quand même une bonne idée
je voudrais une quarantaine de pommes ça
ça nous dit deschamps
est ce que les consommateurs doivent
être rassurés sachant qu'il croque dans
une dizaine voire une quinzaine de
pesticides
maryse bouchard a mené des travaux sur
les risques associés à l'exposition aux
pesticides
le problème c'est que quand on teste la
sécurité de ses produits la cia
donc l'effet combiné de 10,15 pesticides
ça jamais été vraiment testé
scientifiquement donc en fait c'est
difficile de se prononcer à savoir ce
que c'est complètement sécuritaire aussi
un risque pour la santé
personne à la santé publique au québec
ou à santé canada ne voulu nous accorder
d'entrevue à la caméra pour nous
rassurer
l' agence fédérale nous a répondu par
écrit que les pesticides sont utilisés
d'une manière conforme par les
producteurs agricoles et que les
canadiens ont accès à un
approvisionnement alimentaire sur les
normes sont pris soient respectés en
effet même en fait ce que je questionne
c'est la validité de ces normes
est ce que est ce que ces normes leur
correspondent vraiment à la réalité à
quelque chose qui devrait on peut
vraiment se fier moi c'est ce que je
questionne parce que d'habitude ces
normes ont été établis et de nombreuses
années tiennent pas compte des données
les plus récentes
et pourtant il y en a des avancées
scientifiques au niveau des pesticides
sauf que les normes on les revoit pas
très très souvent
la moitié des pomiculteurs travaille
toujours sans agronome et ne savent pas
à qui se fier pour répandre la bonne
quantité de pesticides
cela dit on sent chez eux une volonté de
diminuer l'utilisation de pesticides
mais vraiment con paris quarante ans les
produits sont le risque pour la santé ou
si ça lui beaucoup diminué
puis 10 les deux trois prochaines années
on peut être avoir la chance d'avoir des
nouveaux produits plus de nous des
pomiculteurs en cultures
conventionnelles empruntent maintenant à
la culture biologique certaines de leurs
techniques et certains produits qu'on
utilise un biologique commence est
utilisé en conventionnel
[Musique]
evelyne martin est une des rares à
grenoble en culture biologique
j'ai des collègues qui vont consulter
puis on me dira ce produit là est-ce que
c'est efficace comme on utilise et
j'attends donc oui il ya quand même une
ouverture d'esprit et on cherche un peu
les produits biologiques quand ils sont
efficaces
bon an mal an on a à peu près de 80% de
pommes parfaite donc c'est quand même
très bien
j'exclus un peu le cas les par contre
parce que nous on prend on tient pas
trop compte du calibre mais le problème
du calibre ça l'art est important parce
que les producteurs dans le
conventionnel qu'ils nous disent qu'ils
le nombre de pommes qui sont déclassées
par ce camp juste un petit peu plus
petit est ce que on n'a pas un problème
là déjà de mise en marché
je pense que la clientèle seraient prêts
afin d'aider concessions sur le calibre
si la pomme est belle il ya pas de
maladies peau d'un cycle la culture bio
pourrait être une solution mais c'est
extrêmement difficile de cultiver des
pommes de cette façon au québec et les
pommes bio ne sont pas abordables pour
tous quant à celle de cultures
conventionnelles
reste à billy frotter avec de l'eau et
même du bicarbonate de soude avant de
les consommer afin d'éliminer le maximum
de résidus de pesticides
ces pesticides qui sont néfastes pour la
santé des agriculteurs
c'est indéniable mais c'était pas
toujours possible de connaître les
effets sur nous qui les consomme
[Musique]